you know i'm very glad to be in florida
right now i'm very glad
not to be in uh
los angeles i'm very glad not to be in
california these places that are really
locked down
i'm in florida for tpusa i'm going to be
giving a speech this afternoon
4 20 or so eastern time very excited
about there have been some real
rock stars here rhonda santa spoke
yesterday ted cruz spoke yesterday
we got a bunch of great people coming
out today
and and of course tpusa was trending it
always is trending because the left
finds something to make a big deal of
that and this time
the issue was here's the headline let me
tell you the headline
porn star featured as vip
at tpusa student conference i saw that
that was the trend yesterday on twitter
i said oh my gosh they got a porn star
speaking at
at tpusa so i looked that was not the
case
as always i don't believe the headline
is all whenever you see the headline
charlay kirk is doing this terrible
i said no i don't i don't think that's
true so i looked and
what happened was a porn star decided to
attend the conference and she bought her
own vip ticket
and she was just showing up to listen to
the speakers
and this created two reactions on the
right
both of which i think were wrong so
there was the very wrong reaction
which was hey porn is great
if that's true freedom we need to be the
cool party
we need to endorse porn and drugs and
stuff and that's awesome and that's
going to be the party of the future
yeah and porn is nothing more american
than apple pie
okay so that's obviously a ridiculous
libertine point of view
then there was the more conservative
point of view which
is this is you know terrible this is
awful there was a lot of invective sent
against this porn lady people calling
her all sorts of terrible names and
saying she needs to be shunned from
society and
shouldn't show her face anywhere and i
think that reaction was a little
a little off as well i think there
actually was a
third way here that the conservatives
should have pursued
and it's this had this porn lady been a
speaker
had this porn lady had a booth to do
what we don't know at the conference had
this porn lady been making a big
nuisance of herself and making a big
show of herself
and trying to become a leader or a
speaker or a focus of a conservative
summit that would be a very bad thing
and obviously she should have been
kicked off of the premises but as far as
i can tell that's not what happened
as far as i can tell this porn lady
showed up she was she used her christian
name she didn't use her porn names and
no one
even who would have heard of her had had
seen anything
and she was just kind of minding her own
business and watching the conservative
speakers
isn't that good if she's if she's just
totally minding her own business
she's not trying to recruit anybody for
her
pornography business isn't that good
don't we want that to happen i just
i felt that the invective sent against
this woman
was really misplaced because i got to
tell you
something tells me that if you work in
pornography if you're a prostitute or a
porn actress you probably don't have the
strongest
sense of self-dignity you probably don't
have the strongest feelings of
self-worth
and to be called all sorts of names and
to be told that you're the
root of all evil in society i don't
think that's very nice i don't think
it's nice to
speak in a harsh vulgar way to women
ever whether it's a prostitute or a
princess i don't think that's right
and i also just think if this woman
she's still working in pornography but
she's clearly interested by some
conservative arguments
and maybe she's only right now gone
through like the shallow conservative
arguments
but she's obviously interested if i can
get her into a room
where she hears conservative speakers
where she hears me give a speech
about how porn is bad and you shouldn't
be in the industry and if you're in it
you should get out
and if you're supporting it you should
stop supporting it and if you
are a legislator you should restrict it
or even ban it
outright if she can hear those arguments
and maybe be persuaded
i think that would be a good thing i i
know that when
conservatives call for a big tent party
99 times out of 100 what that means is
they want to just get rid of all of our
standards
and they want to just become democrats
light
if if light or just identical to the
democratic party and not have any
boundaries at all
i know that's how that works a lot of
the time
but the good version of a big tent party
is
we have these standards we hate porn
among other things you can't do that
there's no spot for that in the
conservative movement
but there is a spot for you if you want
to get out of it
this is look obviously i've been
talking about speechless for a very long
time which is available now for order
i don't think there is anybody in the
conservative movement who has been more
vocal about the need for standards about
the need to suppress
vice about the need to stop saying that
you can just say and do whatever you
want all the time okay
we certainly need standards but the
point of standards is not to kick
everybody out
the point of standards is not to be
insular and small and exclusive
or exclusionary the point of standards
is to bring
as many people as possible along to hold
themselves
to a higher standard of speech and
conduct and so
i just i'm obviously much more
sympathetic to the point of view
that you know these porn stars need to
be cast into outer darkness where
there's wailing and gnashing of teeth
but that actually isn't my view
my view is that porn needs to be cast
into the outer darkness
and the people who are caught up in the
industry especially the women who
generally don't come from great
backgrounds and haven't had a great life
they need to be welcomed in and
they need to be given the arguments as
to why this is terrible
and they need i think it would be good
to elevate their their political views
and and so i just think the invective
the meanness
the we we got to ditch that sort of
thing and
and really use standards for their true
purpose
which is elevating individuals and
elevating society
hey stop i'm really glad that you
enjoyed all that terrible right-wing
misinformation that i i just was
spreading you know
recklessly around the internet if you
want even more of that reckless
misinformation
go check out the full episode which is
available now
on this channel it's also available on
apple podcast spotify stitch or google
play
all over the place at the michael
knowles show and you can also order
my book chock full of deplorable
terrible right wing
misinformation go get that too that's
speechless we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you